okami pas longtemps et bien voilà tout
est prêt je vais avoir un très beau zoo
je vais sûrement gagner beaucoup
d'argent
salut casimir elle se serait à bonjour
julie fait que se passe-t-il ici enfin
tu ne sais pas lire grands zoos de
casimir visite à francs qu'il faut que
je te donne à fond mais n'ont pas encore
les animaux ne sont pas là tu ne fais
vraiment attention à rien bon je
reviendrai tout à l'heure quand les
animaux seront là et que tu sera de
meilleure humeur ne te fâche pas julie
écoute tu veux que je te dise quels
seront mes animaux un bien sûr
intéressant du salut
c'est une collection exceptionnelle
il y aura une chenille en têtard un
asticot là un os de cannes c'est
fantastique casini mais j'espère que tu
vas aller garder assez longtemps oh mais
bien sûr ils ne disparaîtront pas autre
voleur n'osera les prendre ce sont des
animaux très rares jeux tels souhaite
bon je vais aller chercher tout est prêt
et bien moi je vais ouvrir le casque et
préparer ma pièce de affront
françois peux tu m'as fait peur je ne
t'avais pas entendu venir axée sur moi
casimir montazeau j'ai le sentiment qui
va lui arriver quelques ennuis que veux
tu dire verra bien on voit beaucoup nos
jours où je ne me suis pas trompé au
calme et éviter le roller vite oui et
ils sont allés chercher le plus grand
détective du monde avec que s'est il
passé
les animaux demongeot ont rendu les
avants les tous mettez-y mais qu'est-ce
que du avec comme animaux j'avais une
chenille un pétard on a stick haut et un
autre de cannes casimir c'est une
accusation très grave et est ce qu'il
n'ya aucune autre explication leur
disparition
mais non je suis sûr qu'on me les avants
lewy écoute casimir je pense que
françois va pouvoir aider à résoudre
tout problème c'est un principe pour une
affaire ausssi importante qu'il me faut
un grand monde
casimir ne t'inquiète pas justement il
est de passage sur notre île les plus
grands détectives du monde mais bien sûr
tu ne savais pas bien tu vas voir c'est
une idée à mort ou mytho fais tu là il
faut vite aller le chercher le grand
détective alors oui j co qui courent
[Musique]
tu crois qu'ils l'ont retrouvé tiens
regarde le voit la rue vous mentent me
connaissez mieux que je suis malade
comme le plus grand détective du monde
j'ai bien compris tout de suite que vous
étiez il est formidable
et bien voilà monsieur merl encore flou
mais ne dit rien
je vois que tous les animaux de votre
eau à lesparre eu qu'il est
extraordinaire
vous voulez que je vous parle de ces
animaux
oh vous aviez de tout et tu es très
petits animaux
quels étaient les gens c'est vous avez
dû passer beaucoup d'examens monsieur
fils max
je vais donc réunir tous les témoins
ayant recours à des enfants dans ce
genre mais oui c'est formidable comment
savez vous voulez vous que les centrales
mais c'est indispensable pour mon hockey
serait bien c'est faux vénéjan fort
venez venez vite venez vite
alors monsieur votre numéro un
animaux eh bien j'avais dans la première
case là une adorable petite sunny verte
avec des yeux noisette les enfants en
quoi une adorable petite chenille avec
des yeux noisette peut-elle se
transformer en papillon
oui je suis quasiment un papillon et
l'animal numéro 2 points justement j'ai
vécu à l'heure un papillon rouge et bleu
alors ça devait être lui là dans le
bocage j'avais un splendide petit écart
1 semaine des petites total en quoi peut
se transformer they call les enfants et
chez vous réfléchissez aussi
une grenouille une relookeuse et murs ah
bon je souhaite être animal troisième
mais là j'avais eu un très bel âge qui
compte ou jaune à la chicotte
à quoi peut se transformer un échec les
attaques ouah ça se transforme en une
peut-être une bouche une rouge lestés
coach était comme un jeu m'a mis en
bouche et ensuite le 4 animal mon
asticots se transformer en monstre mais
il a alors là j'avais un très bel homme
de cannes le petit peuple de cannes 9 le
nian en quoi peut se transformer en
oeuvres de can tho un petit canard
petits canetons mais justement sur le
chemin en revenant j'ai rencontré un
petit canetons tout jaune
et bien voilà monsieur simon était
terminée aucun animal ne vous activerez
se sont transformés et bien voilà un
résultat très heureux monsieur marc
lafosse
mais c'est parce que comme ça nous
savons qu'il n'ya pas de voleurs dans
l'île aux enfants mais très heureuse et
je vous suis très reconnaissant monsieur
forme est ce parce que grâce à vous nous
avons évité une terrible erreur
judiciaire
que voulez vous dire
c'était bien imaginez vous que notre ami
françois voulait mener lui même s'étant
hockey vous imaginez la catastrophe que
ça aurait donné françois monod l'enquète
ou des émirs toi